if you're like me you couldn't wait to
get your eyes on the final season of the
crown if only to master the Dutch Bonnet
napkin fold few have truly mastered the
Dutch Bonnet napkin fold it's hard to
believe that the first season came out 7
years ago with a Cavalcade of actors
portraying the royal family from 1947 to
2005 but like Prince Charles and Diana's
marriage it must come to an end even
though there are plenty of more Royal
stories for a season 7 including Prince
Andrew's travel to Epstein Island Prince
Williams alleged Affair and of course
Prince Harry and Megan markle's
estrangement from the royal family and
be sure to stick around till the end of
the video as I go into what the Queen's
speech the one she decides not to read
actually says now I hope you're about as
excited for this video as Prince Phillip
is taking a family photo
CHR take the photo God's sake take a
bloody photograph will you and like And
subscribe it means a lot the very first
image of the final episode is that of a
fox a symbolic nod to the Royal Family's
ability to adapt in fact much of season
5 and six have centered around the
Queen's ability and sometimes inability
to adapt and change over time there's a
delicate balance of making sure the
crown survives while maintaining its
customs and traditions in fact the
series final episode involves a moral
dilemma reigning monarch Queen Elizabeth
II must face does she break from
tradition and abdicate the throne so
that Charles can rule R in his prime or
does she do what the crown demands serve
until death I declare before you all
that my whole life whether it be long or
short shall be diverted to your service
and it's kind of fitting that the
Crown's final episode sees the queen
having to plan her own funeral an event
known as operation London Bridge while
the events of this episode take place in
2005 it won't be until 17 years later
that the queen dies in 2022 and yes it's
true that the Queen's Royal Piper played
sleep Deary sleep at her funeral which
also happens to be the name of the final
episode another decision the queen must
make is approving Charles's marriage to
Camila Parker BS a decision that sees
her Consulting with the Archbishop of
Canterbury and Bishop of Salsbury
remember that the Monarch is the head of
the Church of England and the church
doesn't want it to seem like they're
condoning sinful Behavior by approving a
marriage that was founded in sin and yes
during their own wedding Charles and
Camila had to repent and ask forgiveness
for their sins well part one of season 6
primarily focused on Princess Diana part
two spends most of its time on William
we pick up with him shortly after the
death of his mother I just want things
to go back to normal as quickly as
possible but rather than process his
grief he shuts it out becoming
increasingly isolated from everyone
including his father set this against
the backdrop of Will's Mania where
swells of teenage girls basically throw
themselves at him it makes for an
awkward combination what will hasn't
done is Express his feelings about what
happened believing his father's
decisions are what led to Diana's death
don't you think there might be a
connection between where we will are now
and you're part in it it's an accusation
that destroys Charles and opens up even
more wounds such as William believing
Charles resents him because he's more
popular and more like Diana you think
I'm just like her and you hate me for it
it's only when will has a heart-to-heart
with his grandfather Prince Phillip that
William realizes it's easier to be mad
at his father than accepting who he's
really angry with his mother but how can
a son really be mad at his own dead
mother it's an agonizing position to be
in Diana not only left him but left him
with impossible shoes to fill he's not
as comfortable in the spotlight doesn't
have as good away with the public and
there must be some underlying resentment
here it's only when he realizes this
that William goes to his father and
without saying anything gives him a big
hug I think for me this was the most
emotional part of part two and a Prof
found lamentation on how we process
grief but it's not all sad for the young
princess episode 7 delves into his love
life an eventual relationship with Kate
Middleton now the show will have you
believe that Kate met William in her
early teens while he was out with
Princess Diana but official statements
say they met each other during the first
few weeks attending St Andrews
University in Scotland Kate was deemed
to be the prettiest girl at school and
William and Kate both took art history
and shared a mutual love for swimming
which we'll see in the show it's also
true that Kate switched from the
University of Edinburgh to St Andrews
after the announcement William would be
attending but we can't be certain what
her true intentions were St Andrews did
see a 40% increase in applications after
the Royal announcement it wasn't a hot
love affair right off the top as a
romance between these two took a bit of
time the show depicts William having a
girlfriend named Lola airdale Cavendish
concade try say that three times fast
well Lola isn't a real person she's
believed to be based off two women from
Williams p past first Carly Massie Burch
who William dated for a few months and
Arabella Musgrave who seems to be more
of that socialite type and now heads PR
for Gucci as seen in the show Kate dated
fourthe rert Finch considered the best
catch at St Andrews they dated for less
than a year but the show insinuates Kate
was only seeing finchy to make a point
to her mother that she can't meddle in
her love life as fate would have it Kate
and wills romance would Blossom during
the night of the fashion show while it
took a few months for them to become
official they would go on to share a
flat together the show also paints
Kate's mother Carol played by Eve best a
royal in another low-budget show as the
real Matchmaker here purposely signing
up her daughter on different events so
that she'd be closer to the prince
however there's no evidence to support
this I thought it was interesting that
multiple times throughout Will's Arc
we'll see a copy of JD salingers Catcher
in The Ride near him it's a book that
has themes of alienation depression loss
grief sexuality and coming of age all
things William goes through in no doubt
would be able to connect with the final
episodes also sew the seeds of Prince
Williams eventual estrangement from
Prince Harry in episode 5 we'll see them
being Bros enjoying drinks together and
being there for one another this slowly
erodes the further we get along and
long-term resentment builds William is
seen as the perfect first child allowing
Harry to be the Royal screw-up he's even
referred to as the backup cuz there's no
need for number two in this
family except as entertainment Harry
lashes out getting caught smoking weed
and of course leading to his biggest
mistake dressing up as a Nazi but
resentment can go both ways in episode 9
William expresses how Harry can do
whatever he wants well he has to be
perfect there's more freedom with Harry
but as Harry States there's one thing
William has that he never will
protection from the system you may have
heard the term the system throughout all
six seasons especially in season 6 it's
a broad term for every protocol that
encompasses the monarchy and they're in
place place to protect its survival if
William screws up the system will be
there to protect him and his image not
so much for Harry the system protects
number
one number two tends to the queen would
know her sister Margaret number two was
known to be much more Reckless and in
need of care than herself the system
protecting Harry is almost non-existent
case in point the Nazi costume in fact
Philip calls the costume shop to chew
them out not for renting a Nazi uniform
to his grandson son but rather for the
historical inaccuracy that Nazi soldiers
in the Africa core never wore swastika
armbands now the show depicts William
Kate and Harry picking out costumes
together which is not what happened
according to Prince Harry he called
William and Kate and told them about his
idea to dress up as a Nazi and they both
loved it he'd even try it on for them at
home and they supposedly howled with
laughter this is quite different from
the show in which Kate expresses her
reservations I don't know maybe cover
the SW Harry would go on to say quote it
was one of the biggest mistakes of my
life and in an effort to salvage His
Image speaks with rabbis and Holocaust
Survivors given a short epilogue is
Dodie fed's father Muhammad whose quest
to implicate the royal family in the
death of his son and Diana leaves him
angry and bitter after the investigation
shows his accusations to be unfounded
while I couldn't find the exact speech
where he refers to English people as
electing donkeys and in caves
the man never held back his views of the
Royals and especially Prince Phillip but
his Philip is a gangster is a bloody
Nazi German bastards come from nowhere
right come on tell us how you really fa
this is a complete reversal from the
Muhammad we saw in season 5 who adored
the Royals and did everything in his
power to earn a place among them not
realizing that no matter what he did or
how rich and wealthy he became they
would never accept
him as we embark on the Crown's final
episode we're met with the backdrop of
the Iraq War to 2 years in to be exact
Prime Minister Tony Blair seen in almost
this Godlike status when first elected
has plummeted in popularity it just goes
to show how politicians come and go but
the crown always remains Charles asked
the queen to allow him to marry Camila
something she ultimately agrees to but
things get exciting when rumors spread
that the queen has prepared a speech
that she's allowed no one to read many
of the Royals including Charles think
that this secret speech will be the
Queen's announcement that she is
stepping down to let Charles rule
according to Royal historians the queen
never seriously considered abdication
but the show makes the tension of the
Queen's decision one of the focal points
of the finale we'll even see the queen
skip through several of these note cards
which have this announcement on it
suggesting her decision was left to the
last moment if you zoom in on the note
card you can see what the show has
written down the first thing I want to
bring to your attention is the page
number on the top right the queen flips
from page five to page eight leaving out
three whole pages from the speech which
is probably why William says nice speech
granny though surprisingly short now
it's a bit hard to read and I had to do
some zooming in and capture a few frames
but it more or less reads as follows it
has become a cherished Axiom that the
crown is for Life a truth that is
constantly impressed in those who wear
it in a thousand years of blank her
thumb blocks the word here the only
exceptions are those who have been
deposed those who have been proven unfit
and often a mixture of the two the rest
I can pick out only a word or two but
this definitely proves at least by the
show's depiction that the queen waited
till the last moment to make her
decision it's fitting that the Crown's
final scene starts at St George's Chapel
at Windsor Castle the place where the
queen will eventually be buried Prince
Philip has a particularly Grim outlook
on the monarchy quoting a line from poet
John Dryden stating all human things are
subject to Decay and when fate summons
monarchs must obey he's essentially
stating that nothing human can last
forever and since the monarchy is a
human construct it must one day come to
an end the queen sees a vision of the
piper playing her lament as she walks
past her own coffin crown and Rod this
is all in her head as the camera
switches to the wide shot and the coffin
is no longer there but the queen isn't
alone alongside her are past versions of
herself note how her current form is
dressed in white while her past selves
are in Black almost funeral like
suggesting they are dead and in her past
the final shot is over a minute long a
minute and 15 seconds to be exact and it
felt as long as the Queen's Reign
herself the final image is that of a
flood of White Light bathing the queen
as she exit symbolic of her entering
into the next life although she still
has several more years until her death
this was a way for the show to end in a
way that elicits this feeling of closure
without actually showing her die with no
season to show her final years I thought
this was a good way to end things but
that still leaves a lot of stories yet
to be told Creator Peter Morgan hasn't
stated what his next project will be but
no doubt they could do an entire series
just on the Prince Harry Megan Markle
drama alone I'm excited to see what
project he comes up with next but now I
turn it over to you what did you think
of the crowns series finale I want to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
thanks for watching please be sure to
like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram @ thinkstory YT until next
time remember few have truly mastered
the Dutch Bonnet napkin fold